The center is at negative 2,3, since we take the opposite signs in the
parentheses. The opposite of positive 2 is negative 2, and the opposite of
negative 3 is positive 3. This is our h and our k. The value of a is the square
root of 25, which equals 5, and the value of b is the square root of 36, which
equals 6. Great work if you got these three correct. Now, what's even more
important is your graph. Let's see if yours will match mine. We'll start with
an ellipse, as usual and it will be centered at negative 2, 3. Negative 2 in
the x direction, positive 3 in the y direction. We move 5 units left and right
from the center, and 6 units up and down from that center to form our ellipse.
Now, we draw in our dashed rectangle around our ellipse, and then we draw in
the two diagonals. Now we're ready to create our hyperbola. The x squared term
comes first. So we know our hyperbola will open left and right. We'll split our
ellipse in half and we'll flip the two ends out, so that way we get the graph
of our hyperbola. Nice work if you got this graph.